- [Narrator] Smoke rising through the air,
and papers scattered across the ground
as far as the eye can see.
(speaking foreign language)
This video shot by a
resident shows the aftermath
of an explosion at an apartment building
in Chernihiv, Ukraine on March 3rd.
At least 47 people died
in Russian bombings
in this city that day.
Many other strikes have
directly hit civilians.
Schools, houses, and evacuation routes
in the country have been
attacked and severely damaged,
on top of infrastructure
including this children's hospital.
- Russia's denied targeting
civilians, but our reporting
in Ukraine and videos show that in fact,
civilians have been badly hit.
- [Narrator] Journal reporters
and the news intelligence
agency Storyful corroborated
dozens of video clips shared
by Ukrainian officials and residents.
Analysis of those videos shows that,
despite the Kremlin's denials,
Russian forces have been
hitting civilians across Ukraine
as resistance slowed
their military advances.
Chernihiv is a city in Northern Ukraine,
home to more than 280,000 people.
A strategic location northeast
of Kyiv, and near the border
with Belarus has led to a heavy presence
of Russian forces in the area.
Near the building seen in this
footage, there's a hospital,
a hotel, shops, but no sign
of Ukrainian military presence
or facilities, apart
from a checkpoint manned
by a few volunteers,
according to residents.
In that neighborhood, a
dash cam recording posted
to social media shows
the powerful explosion.
(device exploding)
Footage shows a children's
playground after the blast,
as well as the remains of a pharmacy
which Google Earth images show
previously looked like this.
- This is a place you, you
know, go shopping, and take
your kids to to go and play in
the playground a little bit.
It's a very quiet,
pleasant, residential area.
- [Narrator] The woman
who shot this video,
who is also a journalist,
told the Wall Street Journal
that she was shopping
when the attack happened.
She rushed home, where her
son was with his grandmother.
- Her son and his grandmother
survived, but you see,
you know, they're now in
a difficult situation,
no gas, electricity,
everything smashed up,
terrible destruction.
- [Narrator] The family
managed to flee a few days
after the attack.
But in many cities under
siege, residents say
they've been trapped, and
are struggling to survive.
In the southern city of Mariupol,
there were scenes of desperation
as dead bodies could be seen
uncollected on the streets.
(speaking foreign language)
Ukraine and Russia said more
than once that they had agreed
on some logistics for
humanitarian quarters
to let residents flee some
cities, including Mariupo,
but efforts were complicated
by continued fighting.
On March 9th, President
Volodymyr Zelenskyy was one
of several Ukrainian
officials to share videos
showing a severely damaged
children's hospital.
Russia's Foreign Minister said
the hospital was being used
as a base by Ukrainian fighters,
a claim denied by the city's mayor.
(speaking foreign language)
Those trying to leave
have also faced attacks.
According to the mayor of Irpin,
at least eight civilians
were killed by shelling
during an evacuation attempt
in this suburb of Kyiv.
Scenes of destruction resemble
each other across Ukraine.
In Zhytomyr, which is located
west of Kyiv, video shows
a school building reduced
mostly to rubble on March 4th.
The footage was circulated
on a telegram channel about war videos.
- It is something of a strange
target for the Russians
in the sense that it doesn't
lie on the front lines.
- And in Kharkiv, Ukraine's
second largest city,
large scale destruction of residential
and historical buildings was
documented for several days
in a row after Russian forces failed
to capture major urban centers.
- What the locals say is
that this simply looked
like a way to try to terrify them,
to frighten them by
indiscriminate bombing.
- [Narrator] Russian president
Vladmir Putin has denied
that Moscow is targeting civilians.
On March 7th in a phone call
with a European official,
Putin said his forces
were taking steps to save
civilian lives by offering
escape corridors for residents.
He also accused Kyiv of
obstructing those efforts,
according to the Kremlin's
account of the phone call.
Ukrainian President Volodymyr
Zelenskyy has repeatedly
denounced the attacks.
(speaking foreign language)
In early March, the International
Criminal Court opened
an investigation into possible
war crimes in Ukraine.
With bombs and missiles pounding
cities across the country,
the United Nations said
hundreds of civilians had died,
many more had been wounded,
and millions had fled,
contributing to the
worst humanitarian crisis
in Europe since World War II.
(light music)